[Music]
one of the things that he's very
motivated by directness and i said you
know i've coached a lot better people
than you before
you know i mean right off the bat but
that was that was a point and all of a
sudden uh he's been fun to watch
craig williams the jets defensive
coordinator sharing some of his secrets
on how to motivate his players he he
can't yeah i i don't know how you would
transcribe that big cat but you know you
can't do the bounties anymore if you're
greg williams you got to come up with
another way to get the most out of your
players so i guess insulting them and
saying i've coached better players than
you that's the best way to get guys
motivated and williams separately said
that the reason he keeps getting hired
is culture culture beats strategy any
day of the week it's how you find ways
to play tougher work harder it comes
from an attitude i
i guess that that has some value but you
still have to have a decent scheme or
you can have a bunch of guys out there
who are very driven and motivated but
they know what the hell they're doing
so you don't you think this is a stupid
comment by him because i saw some
blowback on twitter i agree with greg
williams i think i think it's part of it
i think it's part of it i think it's
it's not but i think your scheme still
has value over real value of course your
scheme has value but when you think of
like you know schemes you you usually
think more on the offensive side of the
ball and trying to get guys open if you
have dudes on the defense a lot of times
you can just play straight up and beat
them and i wouldn't want this from my
head coach if my head coach said this
i'd be like are you serious right now
you have to be smarter than that you
have to be thinking how can we out
scheme the other opponent if you look at
you know the super bowl bill belichick
out-schemed sean mcvay it was obviously
culture was part of it but that was
really what it came down to but in terms
of coordinator if you're talking about
defensive coordinator this is kind of
what i want out of my defensive
coordinator i want my defense to play
with an edge i want them to be mad i
want you know them to all have a chip on
their shoulder and if greg williams can
do that then greg williams is a good
defensive coordinator in my mind
i mean here's the bottom line seven
years ago when the bounty stuff was
unfolding in new orleans and all the
stuff came out and those ridiculous
comments kill the head in relation to
frank gore the things he was saying that
got taped as part of that that steve
gleason documentary and that all came
out in the aftermath of the bounty
scandal and then greg williams provided
an affidavit that that pointed a finger
at jonathan velma for indeed putting ten
thousand dollars or whatever the amount
was on the table prior to the 2009 nfc
championship game i took all that stuff
together and i thought this guy is never
going to coach again in the nfl he's
going to be a pariah that tells you how
good he is he was able to overcome all
of that and still be gainfully employed
all these years later because he does
bring something to the table that does
get his players ready that does give
them the right attitude and the right
approach and yes some of the weapons
have been taken out of his arsenal
because of the bounty scandal and the
other embarrassments that emerged seven
years ago but he still knows how to push
buttons to get guys in the right mindset
to go out and do what they have to do
because ultimately it's a physical game
can you out physical the guy in front of
you will you sprint to the ball and make
a big tackle even if it hurts you to do
it and that's what greg williams gets
these guys to do exactly and i think we
forget that sometimes on twitter and
that's not belittling analytics that's
not belittling scheme and the you know
you know the fact that people have
gotten a lot smarter as football fans
which i think is great
but when it comes down to it if you're
trying to get a defense to play at a
high level ski matters but you want them
to go out there and want to kill
everyone like that's kind of what it is
you know what i mean it's still football
it's still getting guys to want to
ferociously go after the quarterback to
ferociously go after receivers and
getting that culture and instilling that
culture you can see it when you watch a
defense you know whether that defense
plays with an edge or not and a defense
playing with an edge playing with an
attitude that kind of you know dictates
a game it's very hard today in in
today's nfl because it's such an
offensive skewed you know league and the
rules and everything that's going into
scoring more points so having a guy like
greg williams maybe a little bit of a
throwback isn't a bad thing in my mind
i remember before super bowl 44 when he
was defensive coordinator of the saints
and he was talking about peyton manning
they were getting ready to face the
colts and williams said we have to apply
some remember me hits to peyton manning
and that's that's ultimately what he's
talking about the scheme gets you in
position to make the hit when it's time
to make the hit will you deliver and can
you deliver the kind of hit and i know
people get nervous about this now
because of the focus on health and
safety but this is football can you
deliver the kind of hit that is going to
make that guy think twice the next time
maybe he's not going to catch the ball
maybe he's going to throw it sooner than
he wants to because he's afraid of
getting hit again i mean that ultimately
is what football is about to a very
large extent if you can get that guy's
attention early in the game he's going
to be looking for you the rest of the
game if he's looking for you he's not
playing as effectively as he could mike
keys to the game number one get after
the quarterback every single game
analytics high end
there you go i don't know if i don't
even know if you heard mike but how you
beat tom brady you got to hit tom brady
that's my favorite whenever everyone
throws that out oh well that's easier
said than done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports